Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
In this piece of work, we are interested in
simulating the dynamics of water waves.
There are quite a few forces acting on a bucket
of water, such as surface tension, internal
pressure, external force fields (such as wind,
for instance), and gravity.
Therefore, it is not a surprise that these
waves can become quite complex with a lot
of high-frequency details that are difficult
to simulate.
Accurately modeling wave reflections after
colliding with solids is also an important
and highly sought-after detail to capture.
This piece of work simulates Sir George Biddell
Airy's dispersion model.
Now what does this mean exactly?
The Airy model describes many common wave
phenomena accurately, such as how longer waves
are dominated by gravitational forces and
how shorter waves dance mostly according the
will of surface tension.
However, as amazing this theory is, it does
not formulate these quantities in a way that
would be directly applicable to a computer
simulation.
The main contribution of this paper is a new
convolution formulation of this model and
some more optimizations that can be directly
added into a simulation, and not only that,
but the resulting algorithm parallelizes and
maps well to the graphical card in our computers.
We have earlier discussed what a convolution
is.
Essentially, it is a mathematical operation
that can add reverberation to the sound of
our guitar, or accurately simulate how light
bounces around under our skin.
Links to these episodes are available in the
video description and at the end of the video,
check them out, I am sure you'll have a lot
of fun with them!
Regarding applications - as the technique
obeys Airy's classical dispersion model, I
expect and hope this to be useful for ocean
and coastal engineering and in simulating
huge tidal waves.
Note that limitations apply, for instance,
the original linear theory is mostly good
for shallow water simulations and larger waves
in deeper waters.
The proposed approximation itself also has
inherent limitations, such as the possibility
of waves going through thinner objects.
The resulting algorithm is, however, very
accurate and honestly, a joy to watch.
It is also shown to support larger-scale scenes
- here you see how beautifully it can simulate
the capillary waves produced by these rain
drops and of course, the waves around the
swans in the pond.
This example took roughly one and a half second
per frame to compute.
You know the drill - a couple more followup
papers down the line, and it will surely run
in real time.
Can't wait!
Also, please let me know in the comments section
whether you have found this episode understandable.
Was it easy to follow?
Too much?
Your feedback is, as always, highly appreciated.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!